شبح التهديدات النوويه عاده ليطل من جديد
هناك في اوكرانيا بعد تلويح بوتين مره
اخرى بامكانيه اللجوء الى السلاح النووي
تلميحات عادات لتحمي مخاوف حول نوويه
ستشكل كابوسا حقيقيا لدول المنطقه جميعها
في حال حدوثها الحديث عاد الى السطح بعد
خطاب الرئيس الروسي بلادي من بوتين الاخير
الذي قال ان خطرا انزلاق حرب نوويه يتصاعد
قبل ان يعود رئيس روسي ويطفي نوعا من
الدبلوماسيه على كلامه بالقوله ان بلاده
لم يصبها الجنون وانها تعتبر ترى صنتها
النوويه رادعا دفاعيا ليس انت
سبق لبوتين ومسؤولين روؤس اخرين ان لوحوا
بامكانيه اللجوء الى السلاح النووي ولكن
التقارير الغربيه ظلت تستبعد حدوث ذلك
فعليا مشيرتان الى ان مسكوت استخدمها
كوارقه ضغط وتخويف ليس اللاب لكن المعطيات
الحاليه تبدو مختلفه نوعا ماسيه ما بعد ما
تجرى اذكرانيا لاول مره على ضرب العمق
الروسي من خلال سلف هجمات عبر طائره مسيره
كما تطويرها بشكل ذاتي وهي هجماتنا سارت
بشكل كبير حفظه موسكو التي ترى فيها
اعتداء على حدودها التي لا طالما كانت خطا
احمر
[موسيقى]
تسريحات مشاهدينا لم تكن تمر مرور الكرام
بل خلق التفاعل دوليا واسعا في الولايات
المتحده تمت بوتين بعدم المسؤوليه بعد هذه
التصريحات حيث قال المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه نت برايس بهذا الخصوص
ان اي استخفاف في الحديث عن الاسلحه
النوويه غير مسؤول على الاطلاق
اما بلين فقد قللت من مدائا امكانيه
اللجوء الفعلي لسلاح النووي رغم تصريحات
بوتين حيث اعتبر المستشار الالماني
والعشورز انا خطر لجوء موسكو الى السلاح
النووي في عمليتها العسكريه على اوكرانيا
قضاء لا لان المجتمع الدولي رسم خطا احمر
لروسيا على حد وصفه
وارتباطن دائم بي تصريحات بوتين فان الرجل
لم يكتفي بالتلوح مره اخرى بامكانيه
استخدام السلاح النووي بل اكد ايضا على ان
بلاده ستواصل ضربتها ضد البناء التحتيه
لاوكرانيه للطاقه لابوت على هامشي
ميداليات في الكريم قال ان القصه الروسيه
هو ردوا فعل على الهجمات التي الحقت اضرار
جسيما بجسر القرموها جامعه اخرى قامت بها
اوكرانيا